question oui c'est mon ipad
allez on répond c'est valérie bénaïm
tiens valérie mais laïque est en
vacances va t il ça va ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
vous savez ça n'est pas mal et il est
libre de participer comment ça va faire
des jeux sans moi ouais bah oui qui sait
la chouette vous avez une question
valérie oui est ce que madame la
chouette alors et pas des cheveux un peu
taillé and dye fout de ma gueule avec la
question elle pense à des femmes alors
est-ce que vous avez les cheveux tie and
dye madame la chouette c'est ce que
savait pas ce que ça veut dire moyens va
donc ou non non pas vraiment non non
valérie vous êtes tous là je suis hyper
déçue prince salman
[Applaudissements]